good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that great thing that you have
inside you explode out into the world
and have a big impact so to help you on
your journey today's message is take a
holiday from seriousness over the you
said guru just loosen up your life a
little bit laugh a little more involve
yourself with people around you do
things that you think is not so
important don't do things which are very
important do simple things very
important you do simple things very
important things you're doing in your
life you will become dead serious you
know Bertrand Russell and Englishman
[Music]
Bertrand Russell said if you're
beginning to think that what you're
doing is very important you need to take
a holiday
so holiday does not mean coming to
Indiana holiday is every day in those 24
hours you must take a holiday from your
seriousness from yourself seriousness
has come essentially because of your
self-importance you hold yourself as an
important person I want you to see you
are like a speck of dust in this
existence tomorrow morning if you
disappear for sure in India nobody will
miss you even down under they won't
bother much you know a handful of people
they will also forget soon enough isn't
it sir who nature does woof you're gone
and nothing will happen in this world
everything will happen wonderfully well
even if you're not there every human
being should be aware of this every
moment of his life it does not matter
what the whole world says about you it
does not matter how significant the work
you're doing you must understand that
too
Oh morning the world will go on fine
without you whoever you may be
isn't it so if you constantly remind
yourself of this you'll have no reason
to be serious definitely not dead and
don't be dead
now a time will come it's time to be
alive so this is a difficult message for
me to absorb in all honesty I love a lot
of the stuff that Sadhguru says and I
have fun in what I'm doing but I would
say I'm much more serious than I am fun
in my day-to-day work and I think a lot
of it comes from I believe that the work
that I'm doing is important not because
of me being you having a huge ego or
being superhuman or doing being better
than somebody else I believe everybody's
work should be important I believe as an
entrepreneur is what we set off to do we
have a mission we want to make the world
a better place and if you don't think
that your work is important then you
don't work as hard on it I believe that
the videos I make are important I
believe filming day here today is
important we have fun doing it but it's
still important I wanted to get better
you know I'm serious about it and I
think if I didn't care enough about it
or if I had too much fun or wasn't
serious about it then I wouldn't put in
the work if I didn't have that ambition
to really help you guys out and feel
like you know the work that I'm doing
every day means something to people that
if I died nobody would care and you know
the legacy wouldn't continue so this is
where I struggle with this message and I
thought I'd still put it out there
because I like hearing different points
of views and I like using them to
challenge my own thinking and think is
this something that I need to shift my
mindset around
is it true does it speak truth to me or
is it something like meditation as an
example that I've tried many many many
times I'm still open to but I can't
connect to it as much as other people I
believe it works for other people I'm
not saying that they're liars if it's
not what if it's working for them just
because I don't feel it and so I thought
it'd be useful to share the message with
you guys and I left
what do you think what's your opinion
how do you draw the line are you inside
Buddha's camp are you more in my camp
that the work you're doing matters can
you blur the line somewhere I'm really
curious to hear your tag fill up the
comments share your thoughts and I'll
digest them and see if maybe I adjust my
mindset along the way too so that's the
question today what do you think should
you be taking a holiday from seriousness
how you applying that in your life in
your business in your day to day really
curious to hear your thoughts I also
want to give a quick shout it to Linda
filler Linda thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word I really appreciate the support and
I hope you enjoyed the reading so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
does it bother you that expectations
always run so high of Narayan Murthi of
emphasis and you know with the
expectations always running so high and
so consistently high there's a risk of
people around you expecting too much and
hence the facing disappointment does
that bother you at all not really
because while we take our work very
seriously we don't take ourselves very
seriously
all these things bought would bother a
person if he or she were to take himself
or herself very seriously so we don't do
that
so and how does the corporation manage
to not take itself so seriously no the
corporation not the individuals within
the corporation but I was a dancer on
Soul Train okay I am an American
Bandstand Wow they were they were they
they taped across the hall from each
other so I've never done this publicly
is there any music let me uh I'm gonna
get out the way yeah I hope none of my
shareholders are watching my my
investment may go down
no no no no I need something with some
beats - that is far too that actually
might have been like the theme music for
so trainer you know I don't have to do
this so you you didn't you can just cut
that you can just cut the music
altogether
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sure I'll be paying the price for
that later luck luckily that show kept
me in shape and I stay in shape so I
have minimal pain
I'm sure that's pretty unique amongst
your speakers that pretty much falls in
place with my life philosophy which is
take life seriously but don't take
yourself too seriously just have a light
touch one of the diseases that we have
in this world of seriousness people take
themselves very serious and people take
themselves very serious and force other
people to offer suffer from this disease
of insecurity which is then connected to
theater which is then tied to how you
treat other people if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you up or that would be
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details